[Music]
the one with the routine just got an
epic reboot on Monday Courtney Cox and
her 15 year old daughter Coco Arquette
hit up tick tock to show off their
impressive dance moves
yeah that choreography is giving fans
major throwback friends vibes
raus we haven't done the routine since
middle school you know the one where
Monica and Ross Geller's show off their
brother-sister dance routine
[Music]
anyway back to Coco the two crushed it
in the clip not missing a single beat
Coco captioned the viral clip quote
family workout Courtney also shared the
clip on Instagram she hilariously wrote
in the caption wanna see your child lose
their patience do a tick-tock with them
naturally the internet lost it over the
iconic moment one fan tweeted quote good
night to this video of Courtney Cox and
Coco and this video only while another
gushed this makes my whole day of course
this isn't the first time Coco whose dad
as David Arquette has shown off her
moves
care about the console yep
that's a 12 year old Coco back in 2017
starring in mono Gems video for wild
when et caught up with Courtney in 2018
she dished that her daughter might just
be following in the family's showbiz
footsteps Coco's really she's into
musical theater and she's done probably
22 plays already she's absolutely
obsessed maybe more than her schoolwork
she was in The Addams Family and she
just got the part of Mimi and rent
so she's really excited so yeah that's
her passion and I would do anything to
continue to help support women in this
industry so she doesn't have any the
same issues and she has all the
opportunities that she deserves
[Music]